hey 42 here in these technological times
we're bombarded with an overload of
information as we duggedly Doom scroll
through a never-ending feed of the
pressing or irrelevant stories whilst
our group messages ceaselessly ping to
alert us of the inconsequential micro
frauds of people we don't actually give
a [__] about
it's little wonder that many dream of
ditching this digital chaos it's
tempting isn't it lobbing the laptop in
a lake telling the socials to sod off
and embracing a simpler more wholesome
existence but this desire to trash the
trappings of Technology can have a
darker side and I don't mean forgetting
your mum's birthday because Facebook no
longer reminds you
for one man what began as a rejection of
Modern Life quickly descended into a
catastrophic campaign of explosive
violence that left dozens mutilated and
free dead this is the story of Theodore
Ted Kaczynski child prodigy brilliant
mathematician passionate ecologist
and domestic terrorists
from his survivalist style shack deep in
the Wild Woods of Montana Ted built a
series of homemade bombs that he mailed
to his victims blazing a trail of terror
Across America as he waged war on anyone
he felt was responsible for destroying
the Great Outdoors that he loved or
advancing the machines he had come to
despise
so elusive was this reclusive
masterminds that he evaded capture for
17 years despite the FBI spending 50
million dollars on what was the longest
and most expensive investigation in
their history and he might never have
been caught had his own brother not gone
to the feds to identify him by the time
kazinski finally met Justice he'd become
one of the most infamous criminals of
the modern era known to the World by a
name that still makes postmen shudder in
their shorts even today
the Unabomber born in Chicago in 1942
Young Ted stood out like a vegan at a
barbecue at 12 this precocious
prepubescent scored 167 on an IQ test
considering Einstein's was around 160
I'm guessing the queue to copy
kaczynski's homework must have circled
the entire schoolyard
Ted's overdeveloped intelligence saw him
skip several grades but he was bullied
mercilessly by his older classmates
whilst his peers were out climbing trees
and scuffing knees Ted retreated further
into the mathematics he loved devoting
hours to mind-bendingly difficult
equations
Ted treated High School like a Super
Mario Speed Run he graduated early and
entered Harvard at just 16 on a
scholarship
most students leave University feeling
like they've had their brain squeezed
from a mangle and their bank account set
on fire but not Ted his uni scars were
much deeper he willingly participated in
a series of experiments led by Harvard
psychologists Henry Murray he was
interested in observing how people react
under extreme stress Ted and his peers
were asked to write essays in which they
shared their innermost beliefs hopes and
dreams
the experimenters then used this deeply
personal information as the basis for a
Terrain of bespoke verbal abuse that was
delivered whilst the test subject was
hooked up to a bunch of electrodes
this whole thing was filmed and replayed
to the subjects on a continuous loop but
this psychological waterboarding got
much worse because Ted was forced to
enjoy this ordeal not once not twice but
every single week for three years
nobody knows what mental scars were left
behind by these weekly tongue lashings
but it sure didn't do Ted any good
emerging from Harvard with a degree and
the self-esteem of a recently divorced
Mall Cop Kaczynski moved to the
University of Michigan to earn his
master's degree and doctorate and from
there he went to Berkeley where he
secured an assistant professorship
for all his mathematical Brilliance
Kaczynski was a woeful teacher his
debilitating shyness prevented him from
forming meaningful relationships with
other staff members and his students
struggled to connect with him they would
have had an easier time connecting to
Wi-Fi and that hadn't even been invented
yet
head it seemed was destined to become a
professor and spend the rest of his life
in Dusty libraries solving the sort of
sums that would have sent Stephen
Hawking into stack overflow yet in 1969
after 17 years in Academia Ted made a
very unexpected lifestyle choice
he resigned from his job out of the blue
and after living with his parents for a
couple of years built himself a one-room
Log Cabin in the Woods outside the Tiny
Town of Lincoln in deepest Montana with
no electricity or running water and only
a gas stove for heat
now the media played a major role in the
Unabomber case Kaczynski demanded that
the Washington Post and the New York
Times publisher Manifesto in which he
quite ironically argues that mass media
has significant negative effects on
individuals and society as a whole now
there's no denying that our current
media landscape has its challenges and
our sponsor today is actually really
relevant to this discussion ground news
is a website and app designed to help
readers engage with the media in a
healthier way they gather related
articles from news sources All Around
the World in one place and show you the
potential political bias of those
sources they break it all down in a
really visual way and even provide
ratings on how reliable resources and
who owns it for example let's take a
look at this story about Elon musk's
comments on how he thinks the Unabomber
might actually have been right about
technology by just comparing the
headlines you can see certain Outlets
have chosen to pick up on different
aspects of his quote which frames the
way we interpreted the story for me the
best thing about ground news is it gives
you a well-rounded worldview and reminds
us that things are much more nuanced
than they might seem their blind spot
feature highlights stories that are
disproportionately covered by one side
of the political Spectrum so you can
make sure you're not stuck in a media
bubble go to grounds.news 42 to give it
a try if you click my link in the
description you'll get 30 off on limited
access don't miss out and thanks to
Grand news for sponsoring this video
so far as anyone knows Ted's trip into
the wild started off perfectly
peacefully But as time ticked by so
began his terrifying metamorphosis from
kooky hermit into criminal mastermind I
by the destruction of the woodlands near
his cabin he began to commit minor acts
of eco-terrorism vandalizing equipment
used for mining and logging and setting
crude booby traps at local construction
sites
his early efforts included putting sugar
in the fuel tank of a mining truck and
setting fire to a log loader
but these Petty Acts were merely the
bunny slopes on which he learned to
master the black runs that were yet to
come
in 1978 Ted returned to Chicago where
his brother David got him a job in the
foam rubber Factory where he was a
supervisor what could have been an
opportunity for reassimilation into
society ended in a psychopathic display
of anger Kaczynski had been on a few
dates with a co-worker when she told him
she didn't want to see him anymore
rather than take it like a typical man
by going fishing or sitting at home
playing with his tackle Ted wrote a
bunch of obscene limericks about his ex
and posted them all over the factory
there was a young woman called Joan who
had hands that weren't just for phone
you get the idea
displeased by Ted's dirty ditties David
fired him it was around this time that
kazinski made and delivered his first
bomb it was addressed to a professor at
Northwestern University but was opened
by a security guard on campus
it's exploded but thankfully caused only
minor injuries
a year later he sent a bomb hidden in a
cigar box to the same University this
time injuring a student
Kaczynski intensified his bombing
campaign in 1979 and it was only luck
that prevented hundreds of people from
losing their lives this time he stashed
a bomb on a plane flying from Chicago to
Washington
didn't explode because of a fault with
the timer but it did start to smoke
forcing the pilot to make an emergency
landing
had it gone off as plans the aircraft
would have been utterly destroyed
the following years saw a Bomb sent to
professors at Yale the University of
Utah and kaczynski's former employer
Berkeley as well as the president of
United Airlines because he seemed to be
targeting universities and Airlines with
bombs the FBI assigned the case the file
name una bomb from which the media
created his murderous moniker the
Unabomber
but far from being a carefully curated
Hit List it was later discovered that
the victim's names were chosen almost at
random after research Kaczynski did in
the library where he volunteered but
there was nothing random about the way
he built his bombs these were
constructed with the meticulous
attention to detail you'd expect from
someone with a genius level IQ and
nothing else to do with his time but
read philosophy and hunt squirrels to
barbecue for dinner this eye for detail
was also a big part of the reason Ted
was able to evade capture for so long he
made sure there were never any
fingerprints on the bombs he built them
from readily available and therefore
hard to trace scrap metals and every
single component was made by hand he
even carefully concealed red herrings to
throw off the FBI
would have been impressive enough if
he'd been working in some high-tech
secret lair like the budding Bond
villain he was fast becoming but he did
it all in a shack so basic
he didn't even have a toilet the fact
that his bombs were untraceable that he
had no connection to those he targeted
and that he lived almost totally off
grid meant Ted's reign of terror
continued unbroken for a staggering 17
years during that time anyone working in
the industries he targeted must have
felt genuine fear every time an
unexpected parcel arrived in the post
as the years passed on the IEDs kept
coming the FBI grew ever more frantic
the task force dedicated to tracking him
down balloons to more than 150 full-time
investigators and they even put up a one
million dollar Bounty for any
information leading to his capture
despite this Mega Manhunt the FBI were
about as close to catching him as I am
to understanding the point of the
Kardashians
by the late 80s Unabomber had sent a
bomb at least every couple of years for
a decade but between 1987 and 93
suddenly he went eerily quiet it
appeared he'd gone to ground and that
the case would remain one of the great
Unsolved Mysteries of the Modern Age
the bombings resumed with renewed
ferocity in June 93 when the Unabomber
stuck twice in just two days another
bomb was sent in 94 and yet another at
95. tragically both of these killed
their recipients
had Ted being content to stay out of the
Limelight he genuinely may never have
been caught he was that cunning but as
with most terrorists the world wanted to
know why and so he used his battered old
typewriter to bash out a 35
000 word essay in which he railed
against the evils of technology and the
Damage it was doing to the world he then
mailed this terrifying tract to various
media Outlets along with a letter
claiming the bombing would only stop if
the document was published in the
national press
although controversial at the time the
FBI agreed to this demand allowing the
sa industrial society and its future to
be published in the Washington Post
negotiating with terrorists might sound
a little off-brand for the FBI
it turns out they had their reasons up
until this point hundreds of thousands
of man-hours and tens of millions of
dollars had achieved a square root of
bugger all perhaps a general public
would succeed where the experts had
failed after all Washington Post had a
huge readership if just one of those
recognized the ramblings of a colleague
or a loved one in the Unabomber's
rhetoric it was a lead that the FBI
could work with
exposing thousands of people to a very
dangerous ideology was a huge gamble but
boy did it pay off when Ted's brother
and Ernst wild boss David read the
article he knew it once he'd written it
the problem was the FBI had been
inundated with tip-offs as half of
America suddenly decided the Unabomber
was that weird guy at the pub who
dresses like homeless Santa and is
always marving off about how the
government puts autism in your tap water
you know the kind so the only way David
could guarantee his voice was heard
above the noise was to gather some
concrete evidence he hired a private
investigator to look into what dear
Teddy was up to in the woods he also
contacted a criminal profiler to see if
letters he'd received from his brother
over the years matched the style of the
Unabomber Manifesto when it became clear
they did David contacted the FBI and
they quickly came to the same conclusion
Ted Kaczynski was the Unabomber
on the 3rd of April 1996 federal agents
raided kaczynski's cabin and arrested
the bearded and disheveled man they
found inside on account of the fact that
he was surrounded by handwritten notes
on bomb making numerous bomb components
and a ready-made bomb short of sitting
there Arena I'm the [__] Unabomber
t-shirt it couldn't have been more
conclusive
after 17 years free deaths and 23
injuries the FBI had finally got their
man
Ted was soon safely behind bars but he
had no intention of going quietly
despite two psychiatrists concluding
that he was suffering from schizophrenia
he was declared fit to stun trial
given the nature of his crimes
kaczynski's defense team wanted to plead
insanity but he was having none of that
he was so affronted by the idea that
he'd be presented as a crazed lunatic
that he tried to fire the entire team
and replaced him with Maverick civil
rights attorney Tony Sarah who'd
previously successfully defended Huey
Newton leader of the Black Panthers as
his trial had already begun the judge
ruled that it was too late to switch
attorneys in response kazinski tried and
failed to commit suicide in his self
he eventually pled guilty to all charges
and was sentenced to eight consecutive
life sentences without parole
he was shipped off to Florence supermax
prison in the depths of Colorado where
his fellow inmates included other
domestic terrorists Mafia bosses serial
killers and even the co-founder of
al-Qaeda he would stay there for the
following 33 years when at the age of
almost 80 his declining Health saw him
transferred to a secure Hospital
and finally in a very eerie coincidence
Ted did finally commit suicide in his
cell in June 2023 during the production
of this very video
foreign
[Music]